this bright colourful temple located in  southern India wasn't put on earth just  to catch the eye it's also one of the  largest Hindu houses of worship  welcome to the sri ranganathaswamy  temple it is dedicated to the Hindu god  of ranganatha a reclining form of the  Hindu deity Vishnu but this relaxed  looking God is one of the highest levels  of Hindu idols the temple which has over  six miles of walls and over a hundred  buildings is one of the five important  pilgrimage sites along the river Kaveri  for devotees of ranganatha the temple  itself is a beacon of the uniquely South  Indian Dravidian style of architecture  its temples are adorned with pyramid  shaped towers made from sandstone  soapstone or granite the first  construction on this site dates back  nearly 700 years it grew and grew into  the wonder that it is today a site that  will surely settle any pilgrims  wandering soul  you  you  [Music]